et ce matin j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
deux invités Michel Goya bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous historiens
ancien officier des troupes de Marie
mais Jean Lopez bonjour merci d'être là
historien directeur de la rédaction de
la revue guerre et histoire et vous
publiez tous deux ce livre lourd c'est
le renard histoire immédiate de la
guerre en Ukraine cette aux éditions
Perrin on va bien sûr en parler d'abord
l'actualité depuis quelques jours la
Russie et la cible d'attaque sur son sol
et il y a eu aussi des incursions de
rebelles russes Ukrainiens dans la
région de belgorodet est-ce que la
contre-offensive ukrainienne dont on
parle depuis plusieurs semaines à
commencer Michel Goya il y a pas
forcément de lien entre ces opérations
et c'est la préparation de cette
opération offensive que tout le monde
attend ces opérations ces actions ils
auraient pu avoir lieu sans sans quoi
que ce soit par ailleurs ils ont une
certaine autonomie
elles sont destinées alors comment dire
il y a deux types fait un peu de théorie
il y a deux types de grandes opérations
militaires si vous voulez les opérations
de conquête celles sur le terrain
effectivement on parle de cette
offensive mais c'est ce qu'on peut
suivre sur le terrain on voit les
drapeaux qui bougent et qui avancent ou
qui reculent et on voit dans quel sens
c'est à peu près histoire et puis il y a
des opérations de raid de frappe ces
opérations de points on voit quelque
part on attaque on revient et là c'est
beaucoup plus toujours plus difficile à
interpréter parce que on attend
généralement l'effet de du cumul de
toutes ces opérations points là on est
typiquement dans ce cadre-là on cherche
un effet qui est essentiellement
psychologique voire politique dans dans
ces opérations le but il y a aucun dégât
par exemple l'attaque de drone dans sur
Moscou il y a très peu de dégâts il y a
de blessés c'est on voit bien d'ailleurs
qui est très peu de charges explosives
dans ces engins le but c'est vraiment
frapper les esprits et ils sont parvenus
leur aide de terrestre une petite
centaine de combattants russes pénétrant
sur le territoire bielgood ça n'a
militairement ça n'a aucun intérêt ça
n'a aucun effet en revanche
politiquement psychologiquement on
montre que voilà il y a des Russes qui
sont là il y a une position c'est un
pied de nez regardez on peut franchir la
frontière comme on veut voilà après
psychologique stratégique oui alors
éventuellement juste un point
militairement ça peut obliger peut-être
les Russes à déplacer une partie de leur
force pour défendre ses zones il faut
montrer que l'on fait quelque chose on
va déplacer des forces qui ne seront en
moins sur la ligne de front
éventuellement Jean Lopez pour vous on
est part des phase du conflit avec avec
ses attaques de drones notamment sur
Moscou des attaques de drones il y en a
depuis le début alors ce qui est un peu
nouveau en effet c'est que on frappe sur
le territoire russe mais en même temps
passé nouveau que ça puisque dès 1902
2022 on a vu frapper des régions aussi
lointaines que scof ou 1000 les robots
ou la base navale de novoroscisse donc
les Ukrainiens sont hardistes de plus en
plus ils ont frappé aussi le pont de
kerchs en Crimée à l'automne dernier
donc là il y a une confirmation de leur
capacité à frapper de façon très légère
comme des moustiques ce sont comme des
Michel se sont toutes petites charges
explosive qui sont déposées elles ont un
effet symbolique politique beaucoup plus
que militaire et psychologique vous le
disiez mais pour les Russes ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas neutre psychologique est-ce
que ça peut revivifier la population
russe et le sentiment patriotique de la
population russe ou est-ce qu'au
contraire ça peut se retourner contre
Vladimir Poutine
comment voulez-vous le savoir pour
l'instant on ne sait pas mais
ça peut être les deux mais à mon avis
c'est pas quand même un effet suffisant
pour pour que un individu prenne le
risque de basculer dans l'opposition ça
peut simplement alerter les esprits que
ce qui est engagé en Ukraine est en
train de tourner autrement
tous ceux qui ont réussi ont un esprit
normalement constitué doivent bien voir
que cette opération militaire spéciale
qui était censée durer peu de temps ça
avait été annoncé comme quelque chose de
rapide elle s'éternise alors
l'explication qui est fournie c'est
qu'en réalité on se bat contre le temps
donc entre la plus grande la plus grande
coalition militaire du monde et que
c'est ça qui fait très bien les choses
mais en même temps ça alerte les Russes
on voit plein de signaux sur le fait que
ce conflit va dire maintenant la
réaction est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
resserre les rangs de la Nation pour
lutter contre cet adversaire qui est
présenté comme démoniaque et surpuissant
ou est-ce que c'est au contraire ah le
pouvoir nous a menti personnellement je
pense que c'est plutôt
vu les réflexes très souvent qu'on les
Russes et vu le type de conditionnement
qui subissent dans cette comme un régime
autocratique j'ai plutôt l'impression
que ça les amène pas vers plus d'esprit
critique
en tout cas quand j'ai dit ma Poutine de
ce type de
ils sont toujours assez ambiguës on
parle des Russes mais le public visé
c'est peut-être aussi les Ukrainiens ont
montré regardez nous nous sommes
attaqués sur le territoire mais nous
pouvons riposter aussi nous faisons
quelque chose c'est toujours très
tentant quand vous êtes attaqué vous
êtes bombardé d'essayer de
faire la même chose quoi de montrer et
le risque étant qui ne font pas que
subir mais qu'au contraire
aussi très clairement voilà et enfin
voilà on fait payer quand même aux
autres avec le risque d'une spirale
infernale
que ça entraîne une nouvelle escalade
en réalité les Ukrainiens n'ont pas des
moyens de faire la même chose que ce que
font les Russes très clairement même
s'ils avaient l'intention donc voilà
c'est les attaques de drones ce sont des
piqûres mais très symbolique voilà et
puis plusieurs population russe comme
des gens en fait c'est souvent ambiguë
on sait pas très bien ça peut avoir au
contraire un effet de resserrement d'une
certaine façon ça Nour le discours y
compris d'ailleurs l'attaque sur
bialgoro de raid terrestre dit voilà en
plus quand vous avez des nazis avec du
matériel américain qui pénètre sur le
territoire russe c'est un peu aussi du
pain béni pour
alimenter la propagande de officielle
que cette je pense que
ça peut être contre-productif après au
contraire
c'est la population de ce genre
d'opération sont par définition très
difficile à maîtriser c'est de la
manipulation c'est très difficile à
maîtriser ça peut se retourner contre
l'envoyeur et je pense que Michel a
raison c'est aussi à effet intérieur
c'est-à-dire que c'est on on annonce
tellement cette opération depuis des
mois et des mois
on le voit rien venir pour l'instant
qu'il faut donner quelque chose aux
Ukrainiens alimenter les gazettes
alimenter les Occidentaux également nous
en faisons nous faisons partie de ce jeu
aujourd'hui qui consiste à dire ben vous
voyez c'est on est la guerre continue
les Ukrainiens continuent à se battre il
faut avoir quelque chose à dire parce
qu'on est dans une situation de tension
en réalité qui est extrême des deux les
deux commandements en chef savent très
bien ce qu'il en est dans les semaines
qui viennent il va se passer
probablement quelque chose de de lourd
et d'important en attendant il faut
meubler cet espace et essayer de prendre
un ascendant médiatique par exemple
c'est toujours un point un point positif
et montrer aux Occidentaux que on a
juste sur ce que vous dites il va se
passer quelque chose de lourd et
d'important qu'est-ce que ça pourrait
être ça pourrait être un tournant dans
la guerre ça pourrait être une
contre-offensive qui marquerait la fin
de la guerre ah non pas la fin de la
guerre je ne pense pas à moins d'une
année fondrement complet de et très
improbable de l'armée russe
j'y crois pas il va y avoir une attaque
il va y avoir une attaque ukrainienne ou
plusieurs attaques ukrainiennes c'est
une opération qui va être montée avec
des objectifs
ces objectifs ont été choisis je pense
de façon à ce que symboliquement il ne
puisse pas daigner la victoire une
victoire importante aux Ukrainiens
d'abord il faut d'abord y arriver c'est
cet objectif
et puis après il faut continuer la
guerre c'est-à-dire de préparer encore
une nouvelle opération plus tard et sans
très bien savoir ce que les Russes de
leur côté vont faire la guerre c'est une
dialectique c'est on est deux à faire la
guerre donc il faut toujours s'attendre
à une réaction de de l'autre
l'armée russe de contrer
si on connaissait l'issue des batailles
à l'avance il y en aurait beaucoup moins
généralement mais bien sûr c'est très
important il faut rappeler que le
l'objectif stratégique ukrainien c'est
de libérer complètement le territoire
des forces russes et pots ils n'ont pas
d'autres solutions dans ce cadre là que
de lancer des grands opérations et
d'obtenir des grandes victoires et une
seule suffira pas donc il y aura c'est
une sans doute une des opérations
offensives le plus attendu de l'histoire
elle aura lieu forcément mécaniquement
et puis là vous avez
pile ou face c'est soit ils parviennent
à percer le front et obtenir une
victoire il faudra qu'il plante le
drapeau sur Melito Paul sur une ville
sur quelque chose d'important et même ça
ce ne sera pas suffisant mais il faut
qu'ils obtiennent au moins une victoire
avant notre petit autre et si ils
échouent si but sur cette ligne
fortifiée là il y aura certainement
doute qui va s'installer très très
nettement si on s'aperçoit donc c'est un
vrai qui tout doux pour l'Ukraine
oui oui d'une certaine façon oui c'est
c'est quand même très important c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça que craignait un
prennent le temps de préparer cette
opération qui est extrêmement importante
c'est vous imaginez le débarquement en
Normandie en juin 44 c'est un peu une
opération qui tout double si elle échoue
ça remet en cause beaucoup de choses
donc là on est dans sensiblement à petit
échelle plus petite échelle dans la même
situation
en Moldavie pour demander de l'aide pour
demander encore une fois le soutien des
Européens et l'adhésion de l'Ukraine
était à l'ordre du jour la vision de
l'Ukraine à l'auto était à l'ordre du
jour et hier Emmanuel Macron qui demande
pour l'Ukraine des garanties de sécurité
tangibles et crédibles qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire et comment ça peut être pris
côté russe
alors ce que ça veut dire il faut être
posé la question directement au
président de la République dans la
mesure où la seule véritable garantie
tangible et réelle ce c'est une adhésion
à l'OTAN or il n'est pas question à la
Scholl cela répétait 33 fois il est pas
question qu'un pays en guerre rentre
dans le temps parce que l'article 5
ferait que ipso facto l'ensemble de la
collision se retrouverait en guerre
contre la Russie donc ça il n'en est pas
question alors ensuite on a on a on a
évoqué différents scénarios pour
crédibiliser et pérenniser l'aide des
alliés
je pense vraiment pour l'instant on se
cherche c'est juste un signal qui a
envoyé vers Moscou à dire la coalition
ne faiblit pas dans son soutien à
l'Ukraine c'est ça du côté russe rien
neuf sous le soleil en réalité cette
coalition elle tient on sait bien que la
grande échéance vue du Kremlin c'est pas
tellement sont pas tellement ces
réunions de l'Union européenne du
Conseil de l'Europe ou de l'OTAN c'est
ce sont les élections américaines
l'année prochaine le grand rendez-vous
diplomatique pour les Ukrainiens il est
là pour eux il y a un risque majeur en
l'occurrence
par le passé on peut citer beaucoup
d'exemples certaines versatilité de la
politique extérieure américaine il y a
eu des renversements
extrêmement important subite la France
en a subi un majeur en 1919 pour notre
pour notre grand malheur mais il y en a
eu d'autres après pour les UK c'est
vraiment pour moi donc les républicains
reviennent au pouvoir et que les
États-Unis changent stratégie vis-à-vis
de l'Ukraine De Santis comme Trump bon
clairement dit que la pluie de dollars
on en est à plus de 40 entre 40 et 45
milliards de dollars de livraison
d'armes cesserait ce serait on a mieux à
faire de cet Argentine donc là il y a un
vrai risque alors ça veut pas dire que
le jour au lendemain ils arrêteront leur
mais il y aura des pressions terribles
pour arriver en arrangement avec les
Russes pour revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé hier en Moldavie Emmanuel Macron
qui a eu cette phrase il a affirmé qu'il
ne voyait pas à ce stade de discussion
utile avec Vladimir Poutine
oui il a raison c'est à dire que on le
voit pas très bien sur quelle base il
pourrait y avoir une négociation qui
puisse satisfaire toutes les parties
c'est ça le principe soit il faut
arriver en point d'équilibre ou
par la force des armes en réalité un des
deux camps estiment que ça vaut plus le
ça vaut la peine de continuer le combat
que tout tout effort supplémentaire est
un effort inutile et un sacrifice
complètement inutile et c'est
généralement en ce moment là que on peut
commencer à négocier quelque chose si on
ne cherche pas la capitulation mais on
en est encore très très loin la Russie
mais le score d'une certaine façon
pardon pour cette métaphore sportive
mais ils ont conquis une partie du
territoire ukrainien si la guerre
s'arrête aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine
peut dire ben voilà on a on a gagné quoi
on arrive à monter un discours on est
très loin des objectifs
prévus enfin annoncer dès le départ mais
pourra dire voilà on a on a protégé on
passe d'une invasion imminente
ukrainienne c'était quand même ça quand
même le prétexte de cette guerre on a
libéré entre guillemets un certain
nombre de territoires on a écrasé une
bonne partie l'armée ukrainienne on a
épuisé l'effort militaire de l'OTAN etc
etc donc il pourrait la guerre s'arrête
Vladimir et victorieux et donc dans ces
conditions oui alors peut-être que oui à
ce moment-là il pourrait admettre
de toute façon il a annoncé plusieurs
reprises tu es prêt à négocier bon c'est
c'est certainement encore de l'affichage
mais pour l'admettre mais du côté
crânien c'est évidemment totalement
déclaration du Président de la
République à mon avis elle est à double
effet il veut dire une chose et elle
veut dire exalement changement au
contraire en disant qu'il est plus c'est
plus dur de discuter il est le seul en
Europe à dire même que ce que ce qui que
il y aura il y aura un moment pour
discuter ça renvoie sa politique du
départ qu'il l'a isolé en Europe et qui
a consisté à tenter de maintenir un fil
le plus longtemps possible ça veut aussi
dire ça veut rassurer ses alliés
européens en disant j'arrête d'essayer
de mais en même temps vous savez aussi
lire pour moi je suis toujours prêt à
servir éventuellement de médiateur que
peut-être éventuellement un jour
pour l'instant je ma politique
traditionnelle de qui consiste à penser
mais sérieux à penser qu'on puisse que
la France puisse avoir un lien direct
avec Moscou cette politique elle
appartient au passé mais elle appartient
peut-être aussi un avenir proche mais
est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que le
fait de vouloir juger Vladimir Poutine
c'est pas un obstacle à la négociation
est-ce que Vladimir Poutine il va se
mettre autour de la table sachant que
qu'il va être jugé alors je sais pas
s'il va se mettre autour de la table
mais en tout cas il va il va il va
réfléchir à si un jour des négociations
ont lieu le choix du territoire sur
lequel on lui avait négociations sera
déterminant ce sera pas Paris
ni d'une capitale occidentale c'est
certain parce que il y a à moins
d'obtenir des garanties de la part des
Occidentaux mais c'est sûr que ça va
amener à réfléchir très très
sérieusement sur le lieu des discussions
mais enfin on est tellement loin de
cette situation que ça peut pas être un
obstacle au fait qui ne veuille pas
négocier
ça ça pourrait ça pourrait être vous
savez je pensais
Emmanuel Macron a un négociateur du GIGN
c'est-à-dire qui essaie de maintenir le
lien avec avec un preneur d'otage voilà
tout en parallèle il y a une action qui
est en cours pour essayer de libérer les
otages par la force voilà donc il a
admis que c'était que tout dialogue
était impossible véritablement bon
peut-être que bon avec un peu plus tard
ce sera à nouveau possible mais voilà
dans ces négociations il y a aussi le
destin le destin du preneur d'otage de
certaines façons le destin de celui qui
a provoqué toutes de cette crise qui
peut être qui peut être l'objet de
négociation aussi
effectivement qui peut être mis dans la
balance mais comme disons on est encore
tellement loin de ces perspectives
chaque chose en temps le fait d'en
parler d'ailleurs
maintenant a aussi troublé un peu les
choses dire voilà il faut pas il faut
ménager la Russie il faut préserver
l'avenir etc c'était pas le moment c'est
pas forcément
idiot comme perspective mais c'est le
dire maintenant c'était pas forcément
une bonne idée donc dans votre livre
vous revenez sur cette année et demi de
conflits vous l'analysez et vous avez
choisi ce titre l'ours et le renard
l'ours la Russie le renard l'Ukraine
pourquoi ce choix
on va dire la vérité c'est une notre
éditeur c'est une idée de notre éditeur
qui pense que une métaphore sur un titre
c'est quelque chose métaphore de type
fable de La Fontaine c'est toujours
efficace en l'occurrence elle est quand
même un petit peu fausse parce que
l'ours il était beaucoup moins gros que
ce qu'on pensait et le renard il était
beaucoup moins efflanqué que ce que la
fable de La Fontaine laisse penser donc
il faudrait un peu bon joueur bon tout
le monde comprend spontanément ce que ce
qui se cache derrière ce titre mais il
faut pas le prendre au sérieux jusqu'au
bout comment vous voulez expliquer
que tu es il y a beaucoup moins gros il
y a eu quoi il y a eu des erreurs
d'appréciation poutine au départ des
fausses informations il a cru son armée
trop grande trop forte ils ont dessiné
une opération sur la foi à la fois de
renseignements terrain mais aussi en
fonction d'une d'une culture militaire
particulière et d'une vision politique
tout ça ça fait un ensemble un ensemble
qui les amène à penser qu'ils ont à
faire à un adversaire qui n'opposera pas
beaucoup de résistance que la force de
l'arête de l'adversaire résiste juste
dans un petit noyau qui se trouve à la
tête de l'État et qu'en s'emparent de la
capitale et en neutralisant ce noyau
tout le reste va
s'effondrer et que par conséquent on
devrait avoir une opération qui passait
quelques combats préliminaires initiaux
devraient plutôt ressembler à une
occupation
en gros ce qu'on peut inférer du début
de la guerre c'est ce schéma de penser
ce chemin stratégie qui a été appliquée
on a vu que c'est un échec total
extrêmement grave qu'il a dès
aujourd'hui Michel je pense prendre sa
place dans les manuels l'histoire
militaire comme un des plus gros ratages
stratégiques de en tout cas du 21e
siècle certains considérable oui bien
sûr les certaines façons alors je suis
dans la métaphora ce matin les les
Russes sont en fait tapis c'est à dire
qu'ils ont lancé toute leur force sur un
coup unique espérant obtenir un succès
décisif d'emblée et puis alors ça
réussit partiellement ils ont réussi à
occuper les provinces de Carson zap
Rogers en partie mais dans la bataille
qui aurait dû être décisive celle de
Kiev ils ont échoué complètement et en
réalité comme ils ont engagé tous leurs
moyens quasiment disponibles dans dans
ces opérations cet échec a complètement
déterminé la suite des événements
l'échec autour de Kiev c'était un
désastre pour pour l'armée russe dont
elle ne sait pas complètement remise
encore et par la suite mais voilà
l'opération échouée et dans ce type de
guerre en réalité de guerre industrielle
moderne soit les opérations sont très
courtes dure quelques semaines il y a un
vainqueur qui s'impose naturellement
parce qu'il est plus fort plus puissant
plus compétent etc et ça se fait en
quelque semaine et si c'est pas le cas
généralement on bascule dans une guerre
qui est au contraire très longue compare
souvent la première guerre mondiale on
l'a évoqué les les
logeurs de mouvement initiales se
transforment en guerre de position
pendant les années mais c'était le cas
pendant les cours cette guerre en
Ukraine et la guerre de 14-18 pour
certains aspects mais ça ressemble
beaucoup à la guerre de Corée par
exemple évidemment beaucoup moins connu
chez nous mais c'est un peu le même
schéma mais la guerre entre l'Iran
l'Irak aussi ça part par une offensive
et irakienne qui se veut une offensive
éclair puis ça se termine à 8 ans de
guerre de tranchées etc donc on est on
est dans un schéma finalement assez
classique ça se compte en semaine ou ça
se compte en année bon malheureusement
ça va se compter
terminée c'est-à-dire sur un gène
d'exposition sur un le statut quantité
et on revient après à plusieurs millions
de morts en l'occurrence million de
morts coréens des deux côtés on revient
à la situation et d'ailleurs on est
toujours là on est toujours dans ce ni
guerre ni paix entre les entre les la
Corée du Nord et la Corée du Sud je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en sera dans 20 ans
mais un scénario d'hostilité franche et
affirmé sur des positions bloquées c'est
pas impensable aujourd'hui ce serait pas
la première ni la dernière fois sur la
gestion de l'armée russe on voudrait
aussi vous entendre la dessus Jean Lopez
est-ce que on n'est pas dans une gestion
un peu iratique de cette armée russe qui
dirige aujourd'hui cette armée et quel
rôle de Wagner dans tout ça alors
l'armée russe elle a un commandant en
chef qui est l'ancien qui est l'ancien
chef de l'état-major général qui
s'appelle
qui était l'homme qui est qui commande
et à qui les unités obéissent ça c'est
un contestable mais c'est vrai qu'à côté
de cela on a des choses qui sont assez
curieuses qui sont le résultat du
développement de d'une tendance à la
dilution du de des moyens militaires
depuis les années 2000 et qui sont qui
se traduisent par l'apparition de
groupement paramilitaire
formation idéologique ou non étatique en
tout cas mais ils sont des personnes
privées avec un financement privé enfin
il y a pas il y a pas que Wagner qui qui
existe il y a d'autres groupes de ce
type il existe aussi des groupes de ce
type dans l'armée dans l'armée
ukrainienne au départ alors tout le
monde évidemment se focalise sur les
coups de gueule de trilogie et on se dit
les rapports entre trigogines d'un côté
le ministre de la Défense goût et le
commandant de théâtre et chef
d'état-major
euh
Guerra simov sont exécrables sans doute
il n'empêche que cette attelage il a
quand même duré pendant plusieurs mois
et permis aux Russes de maintenir une
pression permanente sur ma route et il a
eu l'immense avantage pour dire à simov
de ne pas gaspiller des ressources de
soldats professionnels dans la Russie a
un urgent besoin vu les pertes qu'elle a
qu'elle a essuyé devant Kiev qui sont
pas des wagnères mais qui sont des
soldats professionnels russes donc là il
y a eu plutôt à mon avis
un attelage et une association qui
au-delà des coups de gueule a finalement
pas si mal fonctionné un dernier mot
est-ce que selon vous c'est difficile à
dire vous allez me dire un des deux va
finir par l'emporter ou est-ce que ça va
forcément finir autour de la table de
négociation
ça se finit quasiment toujours autour de
la table de négociation de et ça se
finit toujours parce que l'un des deux
elle a emporté il faut voilà il faut
quand même remettre les choses dans
l'ordre imaginez oui il fait comme ça a
été un peu dans l'air dire une solution
diplomatique pas de solution militaire
il faut faire voilà une souillure qu'une
solution politique il faut amener les
gens en négocier etc non c'est il faut
remettre les choses dans l'ordre il a
toujours toujours il y a quelque chose
qui se passe d'abord sur le terrain
alors ça peut être un blocage
effectivement ça peut être un arrêt et
donc la guerre se termine soit par un
gros vainqueur vaincu c'est clair soit
il y a un blocage une guerre gelée et là
peut-être qu'on peut
comment courir un armistice ou peut-être
rien du tout d'ailleurs ou avoir quelque
chose qui se passera dans 10 ans 20 ans
à l'occasion d'un changement de régime
par exemple
en Russie mais ça se terminera oui
toujours par une négociation un moment
donné oui mais on peut quand même acter
déjà d'un double échec très grave de la
Russie première échec c'est de ne pas
avoir réussi à dénazifier entre
guillemets c'est-à-dire en réalité à
reprendre le contrôle et à vastaliser
l'Ukraine qui était l'objectif de départ
et la deuxième chose qui motive et qui
motivait l'ensemble de la démarche
coutinienne c'était l'OTAN qui se
retrouve exactement avec un auteur
renforcé sur sa frontière nord Finlande
bientôt Suède et probablement à une
échéance encore inconnue difficile à
évoluer avec une entrée de l'Ukraine
dans le temps donc du point de vue
stratégique globalement c'est une très
mauvaise affaire pour les Russes merci
beaucoup merci Jean Lopez merci Michel
Goya d'être venu nous éclairer sur ce
conflit en Ukraine je remonte votre
livre l'ours et le renard histoire
immédiate de la guerre en Ukraine cette
éditions Perrin pour tout comprendre des
clés de ce conflit merci messieurs
d'être venu on passe au club de Tata